yeah no wonder in hand go and welcome to
this video it was a very weird start yet
somehow hate the sound got delayed very
strange anyway so let's get going here
with her with her win Bishop c5 but I
balsamico hmm galaxy 3 years correct him
but it's not please I really don't know
this opening manuel c3 and deform let's
go see three if i go d3 here that would
be an anti berlin problem and this is
probably easier for me to play it's not
critical ready for blackie i think em
come ok default wasn't yet a problem but
now he has to be a with it d 45
threatens to win a piece so he has to do
something about it yeah castles is one
way and d for now it just goes to be six
i think this is not helping me at all
yeah I probably just develop here it
looks a little bit like an Italian game
where the bishop is on b5 which is
probably not helping all that much but
it shouldn't be an issue so um rookie
one it's probably nice you form not not
something I like to see if I go h3 is
got tonight h5 maybe but I can take the
65 so that's not working yeah I'm not so
much at home here in this in this type
of game so I sometimes need to UM need
more time to figure things out that more
experienced 24 player probably no sir
my heart but I'd like to broaden my
repertoire position types a little bit
this is why I'm playing more you for me
simply it sometimes leads to problems
but I hope to benefit from it in the
long run also for my for my students so
that I have some experience with those
positions as well yeah I decided I start
to like four white forget to g3 and can
play a later deform that looks like a
decent position I wonder about night h5
in this particular moment yeah I cannot
go nite xe5 probably yeah I don't know I
was I'm always concerned about those
things not age 52 f or if they might
help black ok my time spent that has
evened out with a little bit ok maybe I
can go here actually for Queen f3 + 9 f
5
oh so he allows me to take on g6 that's
interesting yeah not sure however if
this is doing all that much the FR could
be useful for black ok I think this is
more interesting it looks they're very
similar we both put a night on f5 and
therefore that I can actually attack it
here with creature f3 and I don't don't
quite know if Black now has something
better then just going back I think I'm
just threatening to win this pawn there
there shouldn't be any compensation so
he probably has to go back esox or g6g
six looks very sad he's coming he
started on that square so maybe 26 to
allow possible 92 g5 I don't know I like
my position ethic maybe I'm a little bit
better here being more active okay I'm
just preventing 95 not sure how
problematic it really was but ok so what
is he trying to do maybe like 98 and g6
then have h five so i'll see if i
connect rooks yeah i have h five year
but
and I wonder if g6 is actually a threat
I mean f7 is this is hanging somehow
hmm
huh just think I can also play pawn to H
595 Queen g4 hmm I'm not sure if this is
doing much okay so g6 I don't I don't
cannot answer it with a sacrifice I
don't see it so I garage five hmm i was
expecting g six actually but this one
but it it's certainly not bad dis that's
fibration so um what to do here and move
the Queen to d4 looks a bit strange
going into the pin but just six is kind
of annoying so let's do it I'm down to
one minute ok night to d5 would be good
now let's see me time morning so
essentially i cannot take them because
of the g6 idea interesting news takes
takes g6 mmm yeah and he's threatening
g6 it's definitely true ok right FYI was
interesting interesting yes night h3y if
it goes G 693 night h3 Wow
okay let's see 95 near 95 is annoying
him 20 seconds I can take h5 I'll it's
shaky game here learn to say the least
the first game of a session always is
critical but this one is really awful
really awful don't know if that was so
great g4 is the big issue at least
that's what I think 12 seconds that
that's going to be tricky high five
points a potential issue i get to differ
though
push your personal squares check blood
coming for a long time no challenges
whoa okay that was tough yeah not a good
game really not those first first games
they are always tricky I mean I really
from from over those years I know that I
often don't read new caught them because
they they they always feel like oh yeah
I need two games or three games to get
into stride but ok let's see um that was
a slow slowish opening here with see 3d
three and I think it was a pretty normal
for a long hard and then I started to
play something strange I think after
here and we are with the normal grounds
of the the riddle pass or the Italian
game it could discard a position that
could pop up from both both those
openings so night age form and now we
played 96 that's an interesting overly I
wonder maybe with hindsight I should
have taken I was not sure if this is a
good move or not rly I was a little bit
concerned about the f file however it is
a structural weakness maybe this is
actually this maybe this isn't all that
great for black hair if you consider
like d for him I get Bishop e3 and
develop will probably play this
yeah the f file is probably not very
relevant so I should probably take it I
mean not that this is terrible but maybe
I should take on gee 69 f form and yeah
the next sequence is probably I mean
this looks completely completely normal
but I probably should not go age for
here this is sis didn't really turn out
to be all that great the engine wants to
play a form here which is a very normal
thing with him probably just playing
something simple like here to connect
rooks also isn't bad somehow this is
didn't pan out so well king age 7 the
engine always wants to play d4 md4 I can
never take it and I actually i have d 5
that's interesting I mean if he goes
with this plan that he yeah that you
were playing in the game I'm getting
this and this is nice this is nice his
position is not really all that well
suited for the opening of the D ha and
it was probably better I mean Bishop
teacher was the kind of I have locked
the idea move never went if for I should
play d4 and this was strong winch f6 was
strong now i'm i'm lacking a good move
ready playing this one which isn't
probably good game it didn't see
something something great ready 9f for
was also strong yeah and i went back
recognizing that this wasn't a good idea
genome 96 a g6 what was I was concerned
about this I was thinking on yeah I
could do this but there's 93 which is
looking very annoying
something like this is awful really
awful today I was I was having a really
bad position here after g6 and this also
the added also wasn't great really not
it's a bad structure and he's more
active went here you can probably take
h5 I mean here there are a couple of
things here that that look good for for
him I just wanted some clarity here g5
was also good this fight is absolutely
radium only a couple of moves later
somehow get to get back into this game
yeah yeah it's so bad for black here i
was getting Mike Lee optimistic then
that I may be getting things like this
but it is still good for him and that
was a mistake though I kind of suspected
that that gives them yeah that makes his
Bishop look Bishop so bad this is the
engine smooth
hmm a little bit surprised how that the
engine considered this to be that much
better for black of course black is
better either that's no question but I
was thinking here that this Bishop looks
a little bit inactive and maybe he can
get it to work somehow d 8 and then
still g-form I'm unsure I mean black is
better i'm not arguing about that I'm
just not quite sure about this how he
really it does something I mean these
pawns are all pretty sound pretty solid
and this is what the engine wants to do
my lappy so [ __ ] in cochin able
probably get the special activated sim
ryeom maybe just pawn to d5 and Bishop
to b6 or something no that's maybe the
point yeah the engine has a line like
that actually with d5 yeah okay only
here things were a little bit better
night see if I was a mistake but okay I
was already in total total blitz mode
and he was getting low on time as well
he has spotted that I will get to deform
and ya know the bishop is in some danger
he's trapped yeah 97 but it was pre move
pre moved on oh yeah there was a lucky
win that is so those typical shaky games
at the beginning really okay
guys thanks for watching